I'm in Rio de Janeiro in Brazil and I
come here because they've done a special
exhibition for the International Year of
chemistry and it's on chemistry and the
world so let's go inside and see what
they've got they built an exciting
exhibition which can be dismantled and
taken all over the country Brazil is a
huge country but most exciting of all
for me and Brady is they've got a
periodic table so look here it looks
like an ordinary periodic table but you
can take out the elements and it's got
all sorts of information about it and
it's designed so children can choose an
element the little children aren't very
tall so they choose the rare earths and
the radioactive elements perhaps might
give them the wrong idea and over here
we have as usual the alkali metals so
let's choose this one potassium they
have a picture of the element but the
most exciting thing is on the back this
strange code and the idea is you take
this and you put it in the hole here and
look what happens they sew our videos
Brady and I were amazed because most of
the people coming here are quite young
and don't have very good English they
have done captions so I'm going to
choose my favorite video calcium and
this is my favorite video because the
first time we filmed it I didn't know
anything about it and I had to make
something up so here you can see me but
now I know quite a lot about hassium I
visited the lab in dumb start where they
make these elements and it's fantastic
and here you can see me in dumb start
and what I hope is that with a periodic
table like this we can really
communicate our enjoyment of chemistry
to many many more people
I think it's really nice and it's very
simple but on the other hand you can do
so many things with it I think you can
even put the elements in the wrong place
but we must put them back because the
public are about to come in soon and
it'd be dreadful to lead them astray
well do love in it because you know
there's a possibility to interact with
the periodic table and then to see
something more about each one of the
elements so this is quite impressive for
them and you know our professor Polyakov
it's quite a character so people would
love to see him yeah it's really quite
weird it's also quite strange to seeing
myself so much because as soon as you
see something on a bigger screen it
feels quite different from seeing them
just on the computer on a computer it
feels like somebody else